when i said okay i'm going to do this
year of hell and they were like why
why would you want to do that rebel
wilson may have declared 2020 the year
of health this year i'm concentrating on
health it's a journey
but no i feel good but turns out not
everyone was supportive of her journey
the 41 year old australian actress spoke
to bbc breakfast about her 70 pound plus
weight loss and how her team initially
reacted to her decision to focus on her
health i got a lot of pushback from my
own team actually here in hollywood when
i said okay i'm going to do this year of
health i'm going to i i feel like i'm
really going to physically transform and
change my life and they were like why
why would you want to do that because i
was earning millions of dollars being
you know the funny fat girl using my
body for comedy
always willing the pitch perfect star
noted that while she felt confident
prior to her weight loss she knew that
some of her eating patterns weren't
healthy
i knew deep down inside some of the
emotional eating behaviors i was doing
was not healthy
like i did did not need a tub of ice
cream every night or you know that was
me kind of numbing emotions with using
food which wasn't the healthiest thing
as a result the actress openly declared
2020 the year of health and shortly
after committing to a life of wellness
she told et she shed some lbs while
filming cats i lost eight pounds
shooting my number in four days she
documented her workouts and shared her
progress along the way
smash that
and back in july rebel opened up about
her initial motivation to get fit during
an instagram live
it first started when i was like going
through um looking into fertility stuff
and the doctor was like well you have a
much better chance if you were healthier
if i'd you know lost some excess weight
that it would give give me a better
chance for freezing eggs and having the
eggs be a better quality at first it
wasn't even really myself it was more
thinking
of a future
mini me really during her chat with bbc
she gives fans an update on that part of
her life i'm still trying on the
fertility journey even though like it is
emotional and you get hopeful and then
you know your hopes are dashed and so
it's like i feel for any woman going
through it but i was the classic example
of like a career woman who went out into
the world didn't even think about kids
and then suddenly in your mid-thirties
he's like
oh hang on do i want that as an option
and then if i do what do i need to do
rebel adds that while she still wants to
have her own biological children one day
she knows that it may not work out that
way
it could be great if i had my own
children but i don't know whether that's
going to happen and so i'm trying not to
have any expectations set on an outcome
just that i'm the healthiest i can be
i'm going to try and what what will
happen will happen and in the meantime
rebel is booked and busy i've got a few
very amazing movies coming down the
pipeline the almond and the seahorse um
that'll premiere early next year and
then i just finished a big cheerleading
comedy called senior year for netflix so
lots of big stuff i've been very busy
this year e.t caught up with rebel back
in september at the opening of the
academy museum in la and she revealed
the costume from her impressive career
that she would like to see on display
one day
i do have my original fat amy costume
from pitch perfect and i have it all
properly mounted and everything but then
nobody's asking for that though but i
have it guys if you need it
you